Russia is the discussion of the day
always when it comes to the median right
now it's hard to sift through truth
versus fiction so here's the show we've
tried to be fair we're not Trump
cheerleaders but I think we need to
recognize the legitimate pros and cons
of Donald Trump's presidency so I think
actually looking at the legislative
accomplishments because there actually
are a few if you wade through what the
media wants to cover so once you get
through all of the the conspiracy
theories and the scandals from unnamed
sources and completely unsubstantiated
claims or the word where we can't take
enough winning right alt like get away
from the cheerleading and get away from
the nothing but covering Russia so let's
go through an official list I think is
is fair of the K and I want you to send
in what you think are the biggest pros
and cons of President Trump what his
presidency has been like so some of
these cons that we're going to list you
might think are actually pros and vise
versa but these are things that I will
list under cons would generally be seen
by conservatives as some shortcomings
and the pros some pretty big
accomplishments for him again
legislatively so cons Donald Trump
president Trump ditched his promise to
terminate daca yeah I would say that's
kind of a big one the the dreamer issue
that was certainly one of which a lot of
people supported him doesn't mean he's
having secret secret sex with Putin just
means that was slightly disappointing
for someone who you know I wanted to see
him do something there ah another con in
that same vein very little or if no
money at all for a border wall in a
budget deal even though there was a one
trillion dollar deal that had been
reached promised me so much for promises
I've got to imagine that people who
voted for Donald Trump are disappointed
little pissed yeah that's kind of the
standard we try to use for this list is
what would people who voted for
President Trump the guy who won the
presidency by the way he didn't know
yeah before today we're gonna list
healthcare but hey so here's the pros of
President Donald Trump the Mexico City
policy was reinstated effectively this
was a reversal of President Obama's
reversal and what that meant is it was a
policy that said American taxpayers
could not go to funding any kinds of
abortions or organizations that fund
abortions overseas Obama reversed it one
of his first things as president
president Trump reverses one of his
first actions as president
now if we're going to talk I see that as
a pro I think everyone should see that
as a pro because even if you consider
yourself radically pro-abortion here in
the States
it's a stretch to say that our tax
dollars should help support
organizations that perform abortions in
Zambia don't beat yourself up this is
what I know a lot of people say Neal
Korsak confirmed biggest Pro is is
confirmation hearing and watching Al
Franken so again for people who voted
for Donald Trump that's a big Pro
because the Supreme Court seats were up
for grabs and we thought well hopefully
he doesn't pivot and he actually
appoints some conservative Supreme Court
justices that's a really good start yeah
this is a legislative accomplishment
it's not just about arbitrary will
winning because you're pissing off
liberals that's a big deal put that in
the win column boom another Pro Trump is
pulling out of the Paris climate Accord
I don't know what you always have to be
judging me because I only believe in
science so this is saving billions of
dollars of the American taxpayers money
and here's something else removing
crippling sank sanctions which whether
you agree on this idea of a global
government approach to climate change or
not this deal you know everyone it's
unilaterally unilaterally agreed upon
was unfair to the United States the
sanctions unfairly targeted the United
States so for people who voted for him
who wanted to see the United States do
well not necessarily France
I'd say that's a problem immigration
arrests are up 38% nationwide and
illegal border crossings have slowed
down significantly with some reports
even saying slowing down to over 70%
though that's kind of hard to measure
that's generally measured by arrests at
the border here's the thing why is that
the case people saying well there's no
legislative change there yet
in contrast with other items in the list
he's actually empowering police forces
to enforce the law
oh one that dealt Mayo is chasing a
female with intent to commit rape I
shoot the bastard that's my policy
go figure took a stroke of a pen no
probably just said yeah just a phone
call like hey president Trump I got this
guy here he's here illegally guys do my
job or sit this one out yeah Barack tied
their hands yeah so that's how you see
and by the way
is confirmation of what conservatives
have known for a long time people who
certainly known folks you work with
eyesore law enforcement that their hands
were tied and dealing with illegal
immigration that's this if you were to
say single-issue voters immigration was
a big one for Donald Trump and right
away within the first few months a
restaurant three eight percent that
should tell you something before a
billion needs to be signed and finally
another Pro again this depends where you
line up hundreds of regulations have
been repealed regulatory output is
actually 0.12 percent which if you
compare to the previous administration
administrations including president
george w bush that's very low which of
course the libertarian me was a
fundamental mistrust of government talk
about net neutrality with thomas Haslett
a little later i would say that's a good
thing it's a fantastic thing for
businesses and that's affected in the
market of course when you look at
speculation you know speculators you
look at the projections we didn't want
to necessarily talk about the market
because it it's kind of volatile i
didn't want to talk about the jobs
reports because too soon soon but i do
think that we can definitively say this
is a pretty accurate list of pros and
cons with the president do we miss any
you comment send us your tweets let us
know what do you think of the
performance thus far and by the way for
gonna be talking about russians and
peeing prostitutes and vladimir putin
just go on over to Seth Meyers channel
that's that's what he wants he has that
on a loop like a morphine drip video
subscribe by clicking the subscribe
button it's a kid sinister circle now it
used to be a square which most buttons
aren't squares let's it's on a phone
there's square buttons on phones what
most buttons are circles you understand
what I'm talking about or watch the
recommended video which is popping up in
a box or subscribe at a lotta both
credit a calm slash mont club join them
on clip so you can get the daily show
and that means that you are not beholden
to the youtube censoring overlords let's
be honest you like being there where you
are under their thumb power bottom you